and finally new rule sometimes you don't
choose history history chooses you
that was my theme two months ago when
the Muller report came out that in light
of a rubber-stamp Senate and a stooge
Attorney General it fell to Robert
Muller alone to write the ship of state
Muller heard that call from history and
let it go to voicemail
in the upcoming election I believe
history has chosen another person who
like Muller is uniquely qualified to
perform the urgent task of unseating
Trump by twist of fate only this person
checks all the boxes and positively
answers the question I often hear posed
who did the Democrats have that we know
can beat Trump and there really is only
one answer to that and it's not Joe
Biden I like Joe but if we give him the
keys there's at least a 50% chance he
gets in the car and mows down a farmers
market
also young people look at them like a
typewriter running for president so I
can't say Joe is a sure thing neither
can I say that about Elizabeth Warren
who I like even more but she's a
three-syllable woman in a one-syllable
country a lot of a lot of Americans see
a woman with a bunch of plans who seems
to know everything making demands for
change and they think I already have a
wife
[Applause]
Bernie Sanders is an American hero in my
book but he's an but but he's another
one who has his cardiologist on speed
dial
I like mayor Pete
but we must what we must but we must ask
the question is America ready to be led
by a gay teenager he's 37 he looks 27
he's the only veteran who came back from
Afghanistan looking refreshed when he
campaigns door to door nobody answers
because they're afraid he's a Mormon
and I would be even more nervous if it
was one of the dark horses in the race
jay inslee I've never heard of him and
he's been on this show twice
I mean I could keep going through the
list there's lots of people I like but
when I ask a sure thing
no no no no no no but then one night
when I was self-medicating a name
appeared in the vapor above me the only
person who is a sure thing is Oprah
Winfrey
I don't say that because I'm a giant fan
I'm not mostly full disclosure because
back in 1997 when her show was a cash
cow for ABC in my show politically
incorrect move to that Network she
demanded a second run of her show at
night in the city of Chicago and what
really was my time slot which cost us in
the ratings but who gives a [ __ ] now
that was a galaxy far far away and Darth
Vader's president now
what matters is Oprah alone checks all
the boxes that a Democrat needs to win
one it is crucial to energize the
african-american base Oprah yeah I think
a little more than John Hickenlooper
she'll make black polls rise like a
Kardashian
to the majority of all voters are women
and 58% of the Democratic electorate is
women so does Oprah energize women women
love Oprah more than they love those
shops that only sell macaroons I think
we have an artist's rendering of a
polling place on Election Day with Oprah
on the ballot
if Oprah's running don't get in the way
of women on Election Day or you'll be
seeing the color purple 3 Oprah doesn't
scare white men she's not their first
choice that's Kenny Chesney but never
underestimate the power of being in
people's living rooms for decades that's
what got Trump elected this is now a
as-seen-on-tv kind of country white men
may not love Oprah but she's as
comfortable and familiar as a pair of
cargo shorts with an elastic waistband
if you're talking about the suburban dad
in Harrisburg Pennsylvania with an
above-ground pool three shotguns a
singing fish on the wall and a sign that
says [ __ ] the dog beware of owner he may
not be crazy about any of the Democrats
running but if he's fed up with Trump I
know he would vote for Oprah because he
knows if he doesn't his wife will never
blow him again there really is no under
estimating the value of celebrity in
modern American politics and that's the
final box that Oprah checks I know some
voters don't want a celebrity president
but face it that rule went out the
window in 1980 when Bonzo's co-star got
elected
it's not the way it's supposed to be
it's not the way I'd like it to be but
we officially live in a post literate
post truth [ __ ] society and this
is gonna be the dirtiest campaign ever I
worry most what Trump is going to say
about the nominee for example Elizabeth
Warren has gone to great lengths to
declare herself not a socialist I'm a
capitalist to my bones she says so of
course Trump will call her a socialist
30 times every day until the election
but no one worries about Oprah being a
socialist have you seen the home in
Montecito
and that's just the guest house but this
is not an open letter to Oprah I know
she isn't running and I'm not begging
her to that would be for someone else to
do I'm just saying I have Nate silvered
the [ __ ] out of this and I am telling
you that at this particular moment in
history in this particular election year
she is the only candidate who's a sure
thing winner for the Democrats no
pressure
I am just putting it out into the
universe like in that book she used to
promote the secret and you know what the
secret was that Americans will buy
anything if Oprah tells them to thank
Tom Hartman Liz Mair Dan Savage Deborah
so and Allan Lichtman
stay tuned for overtime on YouTube
where's our cake where's our 500
[Applause]
you